i'm doing 3d printing by this robotic
arm
it's driven by six axis compared with
the
conventional 3d printer it can have more
flexibility
even print like this like this shape
like this this moment
because for the fiber reinforced 3d
printed object
the fiber geometry the fiber part
is quite important but for conventional
sweet printer is
only can do planner printing
so there are weakness between layers
so that's why i develop those hardwares
and also printing logic based on this
robotic arm
the conventional printing logic is print
everything
horizontally all the layers is planar
but for this one two layers is veiled
because the robotic arm has six axis it
can do
it can do and blender layer printing
this is the key layers so you can see at
the beginning
the layer is just a planner just like
the conventional so it's printing
it's flat it's flat yes but it's
gradually
changing to curved you see the curl it's
going
deeper and deeper again
yes so this can achieve two things
one it will much stronger than that
in that direction and second it can
match the geometry
object required so because
the old surface is flat this controller
is trying to bridge robotic arm and the
effector
the main controlling device in this box
is arduino
and there are three main functions based
on it
one is receiving the signal from the
robotic controller the second is
controlling the temperature or the
printing height
there are heaters two heaters in this
it keeps heating and one temperature
sensor
which is connected to the arduino
so by that it can make sure
the printing height can keep specific
temperature
and for the another the third function
is for the motor controlling this motor
speed can determine the extruding
velocity
and this height is only for testing the
two parts i just generated
and this is the official 3d printing
height
it has three different resolution
heights the resolution for this one
is only 0.4 millimeters
which is for worry is shooting
this is 0.6 is for carbon fiber
reinforced polymer
and this is thicker maybe also for same
material
or different material with different
resolutions so three heads
can bring more flexibility during the
printing
it can switch different heights during
the printing process
we can achieve very
accurate locate the specific materials
maybe especially for carbon fibers
so this is the filament
this extruder can push this filament
until the hot end it will melt and it
should
extrude out for this one there will be
three
filaments for each of them so we can
switch it
during the printing when we print
something in some part
we want to make a reinforce make it much
stronger
because maybe this part is a connection
with other devices
so that's the part we need more carbon
fiber
and carb fiber look location is also
determined by the mechanical property
analysis
we do that by software and to know which
part is a
big part and we want more carbon fibers
and for the
other part maybe we can use normal
material
for example pig for the carbon fiber
reinforced peak filament
that is quite strong but it's quite
expensive and for
other parts we all use peak this is pra
very normal
material for the test i'm testing with
single height and with
very common material and later i will
switch to peak
and carbon fiber so this material is
also different from here
so this is aluminum it's only for the
normal
materials for pla or abs but this one
is frozen it can it can do the
peak printing test but maybe for the
long long time using it's not a good
choice
later i will switch to other material
yeah especially for
for peak and carbon fiber this is a
two-part generation because
all those are curves i divide all the
curves into points
each point i can set one command
location for comment for the robot
column so it will just
follow points by point and then
to achieve following this curve can we
see it do some printing
start printing right yeah yeah
okay until i started shooting
working enough for this project
three years so right now the extruder is
printing
following the logic i designed you see
the head is not always pointing to the
ground
just because it's following the surface
curvature this movement can make sure
the nozzle always vertical with a
printed surface
so that can make sure the connection
much stronger
with a conventional 3d printer it can
even it's always pointing to the ground
it can achieve this geometry
but connection won't be very formed so
that's the reason i'm using
six axis robot car if the robot is
actually here
it would probably say that
i might be here i might be here
or i might be here so this is created by
van jacobson one of the great creators
of the internet he's
one of the men who made the internet
work and helped